he was pulling my hip and I was swinging
away to sell the car made contact with
him
um as you know I'm not one to apologize
for things I meant to do but I do
apologize to you sir
um because I didn't intend to hit them
uh I sell calls with my arms I don't
fall to sell a call I don't not a
Flopper so I was just selling the car
because he was grabbing me and pulling
my HP back so I spun away
and unfortunately I hit him and so like
I said I apologize to youf um because I
didn't intend to hit him have you seen
the replay yeah how did it look to you
on the replay I mean like as I've said
before any replay you know if I go look
at every replay of everything um a
replay is that it's never going to look
good you know but like I said I know my
intentions my intentions were to sell
the call um
and you know I also don't think I'm
accurate enough puncher to do a full 360
and and and connect with someone um
so it's
unfortunate last time you got suspended
couple weeks ago they said there a
history of sports like a was aor in your
suspension do you anticipate that
happening again I don't know um we'll
see like I said I know what my
intentions were um and that's really all
I can speak on
[Music]
after the lastday you talked about how
important it was to be there for your
teammates and Steve made a point today
saying they need you to to win games I
yeah I'm aware um and like I said if I
intended to do that you know then I feel
awful about not being there um but my
intentions were just to sell the file
and he was as you can see as I'm posting
up he's moving forward so as I'm moving
back he's still coming forward and um um
like I said it's unfortunate I didn't
again I apologize to nerkish
um because I I hit him so I do apologize
to him and I didn't intend to hit him so
I think you guys have known me long
enough if I intended to do something I'm
not apologizing for it um but I did make
contact with him so I apologize because
it wasn't my intention do you think you
deserve
FL it's it's a hard hit you know so um
if you listen to the definition of a
flagrant 2 it's an excessive hit you
know so I can't
argue that it was a flagrant too
um because I did make contact you know
uh
so
now as I said my intent wasn't to make
contact so if that's a part of the
definition then I know for sure it
wasn't but I made contact and it was it
was it was hard contact so I think the
flagrant too was warranted it's a hit
above the neck um or at least I think
the neck somewhere over here um and it's
hard contact so that would meet the
definition for sure of of a flager to
but as I said it wasn't my intention um
to make that that contact any contact at
all really like I said I was spinning
way and trying to sell the file and but
yeah I think it definitely meets you
know the definition for sure um but my
intent wasn't to hit him I understand
you said the the intent wasn't there but
with this team's small margin for error
and where you are now a third into the
season do you think there needs to be
some sort of Al alteration to how you
approach these situations to not put the
team in a situation where you may not be
available yeah but that's not that that
situation um that situation is me trying
to sell a foul call so on most
situations yes I'd agree with you uh
can't put the team in a bad spot but I
didn't intend to put the team in a bad
spot I intended to get a foul and I made
contact with him
so uh yes in most situations and you
know to Steve's point of course I need
to be there for us to win I understand
that which is why I haven't been arguing
with Ruff since I've been back I haven't
done any of those things cuz I do
understand that you know I haven't
gotten into it with any players um since
I've been back cuz I do understand that
unfortunately bad luck um trying to draw
a file and I made contact with him but
this ain't those same things uh I'll be
the first to tell you anytime I intend
to do something um anytime something was
wrong the the turnout was wrong but that
wasn't my intention so yes um to answer
your question I but I have changed my
Approach on how I approach things but
that's not that wasn't the same thing I
was trying to draw a foul I accidentally
made contact with him and it was again
I'm swinging away like he's holding my
hip I don't think I don't know if any of
y'all ever play his nurt but he's strong
as and so I'm trying to just spin a
way out of him holding my hip like this
and my momentum continues forward and
hits him so uh not quite
the the bad situations that I've put my
team in before
um this wasn't that just accidentally
made contact with him trying to sell a
file what did you think about
that